hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well enchanters five
and six of the melodeon we arrive at
some discussions very important for
understanding Ian sums conception of the
Divine Being the Supreme Being and also
its relations with other beings in terms
of what we can call his fundamental or
background metaphysics he is exploring
this for his monks who he's writing to
and for us his readers in these these
chapters now chapter five starts out
with the assertion as the chapter title
just as here it exists through himself
and other things exist through him so he
exists herman's himself and other things
exist from him what we're talking about
here is per se existence or per se being
of the Supreme Being usually when we say
per se in our ordinary speech we don't
mean precisely what ansem is using it
for here so I do want to signal what
he's talking about we tend to think
about it in
terms of if I say I'm not talking about
that point per se I usually mean
something like for its own sake or on
its own account what he's talking about
here is using this this / which is a
preposition in Latin it in a way that
signifies causality a way that signifies
what something comes from we translate
it as threw not through it as in like
you know moving through space and time
but rather that something happens
through the agency through the causality
of another and what is going to tell us
is that supreme being the greatest good
you know the highest being whatever we
want to call it in this case those are
all fine ways to talk about it exists or
has its being per se that is through
itself it does not have its beating
through another it does not exist
because something else brought it into
existence we've seen this in the
previous chapters and it also has its
being from itself or XA literally out of
itself now this is an some things I'm
not only very important by the physical
language but in a certain way it's also
metaphorical language which has to be
clarified a bit all other things as he
says exist through the Supreme Being we
saw this in the discussion of when we're
beings get there being from in Chapter
three also the goodness that they had in
chapter one all of the things exist
through the one single Supreme Being and
from the Supreme Being so he's using
these two terms / and acts that signify
causality and he's going to discuss on
you know some cases that would might be
a little bit of lumen ating for us he
says whatever exists
some manner and through a craftsman can
also be able to set said to exist
through the matter and from the
craftsman so we can exchange this from
and through so you don't think about
this book you know it exists from some
some matter the the pages the whatever
finish this is that they're putting on
it the ink you know but there's also a
craft process not a single craftsman but
something that went into this imagine if
this was a medieval book it was on
vellum which is it some of you don a
product and then somebody is writing in
it like a monk sitting in his study or
in the library and finally gets found
all those sorts of things create an
artifact right the artifact does not
have its existence per se it doesn't
come out of it that doesn't exist
through itself right it exists through
the crafts person and through the matter
and could exist through other things as
well get a very complicated chain of
causality and we can also just as well
say and some is willing to concede that
it is coming out of the crafts person
and from or through the matter these are
fun what it really wants to say that's
very important is that we don't use the
term existing or being through or from
in the same sense in the same way when
we're talking about things other than
the Supreme Being and when we're talking
about the Supreme Being so he wants to
caution us from the mistake of thinking
that existence from itself or through
itself is just like existence from
something else except maybe there's like
a circular relation or something like
that he thinks that this is very
different and it uses this term he says
there's a different exist ND roxio
because translated as
to Nisshin in here but ronseal really
means something more like sense that
we're talking about here or meaning or
you know the account of it the account
of its existence is different for things
other than the the supreme essence the
Supreme Being then that is for for that
that be so what I was thinking about
other things and now we're getting to
chapter 6 he says that you know because
those don't always do the same thing we
need to carefully investigate in what
sense all existing things exist through
her from the Supreme nature how is it
that other things exist he's not
attempting to provide here a
comprehensive account of causality like
Aristotle with the four causes he's just
bringing up three basic kinds of
causality that are fairly commonly
recognized by people who think about
this at the time those who have any sort
of background of metaphysics will
recognize some of these the efficient
cause that is a cause that brings
something into being that act upon it
that you know could be impressing
something upon it it could be kicking
something into into action the right way
that causes other things to occur then
there's the matter what it is that the
thing is made up and that itself is also
a cause for the existence of the thing
it's not just that there's saying
craftsman a craftsman he has to work
upon something he doesn't just sort of
you know through like a magic trick and
pull pull things out of the air even the
magician as we know isn't just pulling a
rabbit out of nothingness they're
pulling it out of a hammer the rabbits
been all along and then we can also
think about a tool or an instrument and
as a cause for why something exists the
way it does of the book would be a great
example many tools or instruments go
into creating this right and this is for
exhibit things
exists through or from another so the
question that we want to ask is for the
being that exists piercing through
itself and XA from itself are any of
these ways of coming into being
applicable and handsome says no it's not
like you know the Supreme Being who is
God came about because matter caused God
to be what God is and there's not some
efficient cause like God maker you know
in the background you know stamping hook
guns or just stamping out one God or
anything like that and it's not by some
tool or instruments so what could it be
he says you know why can't this be the
case anything that exists in any of
these three ways exists or another is
posterior to and in some way less than
the after which it has its existence so
none of these are applicable to what
we've already granted to be a being that
has its existence from itself a being
that is the highest the Supreme Being
the supreme goodness none of these would
work for so he goes and he says I want
that something that does not exist by
the agency of something or from some
manner or come into existence by means
of an AIDS appears either to be nothing
or if it is something to exist through
nothing and from nothing that's a very
interesting thing to bring up isn't it
Ansem by the ways a little digression he
has a lot of very very interesting
reflections upon the nature of
nothingness that we're going to look at
in other videos that can give later
philosophers you to make a great deal
out of nothing it's a real run for their
money meant physically so to go on he
says I think these things can know what
in no way apply to the Supreme substance
but I'm not going to make like to put
together
proof of this and so he says the claim
that this nature of heard from whom no
nature it all exists is nothing is as
false as it would be absurd to say that
whatever exists is nothing right so the
Supreme Being exists it's not nothing
and you know we can't say it's through
itself because itself it's nothing
that's that's an absurdity for insulin
anthem [ __ ] does not exist through
nothing since there's no intelligible
sense in which what is something exists
through nothing what what is he saying
her this is a little bit tricky to wrap
your head around it first it's not just
the things can't spontaneously appear
that's true as well nothing cannot be
the cause for anything there's nothing
that can come out of nothing so if
you've got us something you couldn't
have started with just nothing or you're
not going to have anything as a little
bit of complication following suppose so
a Anselm n says if in some sense he
exists from nothing right so he's
conceding we could say that the Supreme
Being exists from nothing but how would
we mean that we would mean there to say
that he exists from nothing although
they itself and if we want to cut to the
chase we don't have a the word nothing
in there we can just say he does indeed
exist or it does exist using he here
because the anthems vocabulary is
masculine at this point it exists from
itself and then he considers several
different ways to parse this out you
know if we say that the Supreme Being
came to exist from nothing through some
other nature it's not supreme we can't
have that if this nature is something
either through nothing or from nothing
that it's not true itself or from itself
whatever it is and that would be a
problem as well so in what we've got
here
is if we want to take seriously this
notion I'm having being through itself
we don't get any other options for
explaining how this comes about it's not
through some sort of other efficient
cause or a matter or some
instrumentality or aid it's not through
nothing it's not even through some other
something and so this is some this is a
point that is difficult to wrap our
heads around Ansel knows that and he
tries to give us an interesting analogy
here in explaining what's going on and
you notice I've got these Latin terms
here looks loo canary Lukens esencia SI
and ends Luke's is a noun essentia is
also a noun leukorrhea is coming from a
verb I don't want to include up to and
say it should be lucha a or anything I
had a classical Latin more than people
at SI is the verb to be Luke ends is the
the the personal the thing that has that
characteristic that is doing that verb
on Luca rain ends is the same thing for
SI exists to exist to be existing right
so he goes on and he says how are we to
understand that this being exists
through itself and from itself if it
neither made itself nor provided matter
for itself nor in any way helped itself
to be what it was not already it seems
that perhaps this can be understood only
in the same stance in which it is said
that light shines or is shining through
itself and from itself light shines or
is something shining not because these
are something that was caused you know
by something else
the light but that's the very nature of
light which is to shine or to be
something shiny so he says the same way
as essence and to be in being that is
existing or subsystem I follow from each
other so supreme essence and supremely
to be in supremely being are related to
each other not unlike light shine and
shine I need to make another friend that
that illuminating I get the pun there
right at the start but if you think it
through he's trying to say what this
through itself and from itself would be
and he thinks that this analogy helps us
understand this over here